all right here it is by now I think
you've seen it uh a daughter made a tick
tock about her father's book that sold
almost no copies after he worked on it
for like a decade plus I mean this has
been everywhere that that's not what I'm
making the video about what I'm making
the video about is keep making keep
trying keep trying different things this
is just such a heartwarming story of a
single piece of social media creative
taking this man's journey and making it
a best-selling book on Amazon right now
like literally Google these words and
see all the Articles written about it
for so many of you your dreams your
hopes your aspirations your small
business your startup your big business
your your invention you can make it
happen but too many people aren't making
enough content and they're not being
creative enough I've talked about make
content make content make content but
make different kinds of content try
different formats look at my grid it's
all over the [__] place you need to
try different creative strategies